حديث عن حياتنا في عصر السرعه العالم يدور
من حولنا وكاننا
نفقد التحكم بالفعل اليوم مشاهدينا سنتحدث
عن
ه هل نعتمدها فنستعيد السيطره على حياتنا
ونحقق اهدافنا المهنيه والحياتيه ايضا
وذلك طبعا وفقا لما نشرته صحيفه
اذا نقطه البدايه نحو تحقيق النجاح تبدا
من افعالنا اليوميه الصغيره الافعال التي
احيانا يستهين بها البعض وليست التغييرات
المحوريه الكبيره فيمكن لو اقلعت عن بعض
العادات البسيطه ان تتغير حياتك المزيد
حول هذه العادات مع الزميله لميس ابراهيم
لميس صباح الخير صباح الخير اتفضلي
ست عادات ستغير حياتك للافضل لو اقلعت
عنها اولا الاستيقاظ مبكرا في موعد محدد
فعدم التزام في ذلك يوميا يضر بانتاجات
الشخص والنوم لمزيد من الدقائق قد يؤثر
على شعورك بالراحه والنشاط ثانيا تجنب
تعدد المهام وخصص وقتا لكل مهمه فان انجاز
عده مهام معا قد يشعرك بالرضا لكن العقل
قد يصاب بالتوتر ويفقد انتاجيته ثالثا عدم
تاجيل المهام حتى اللحظه الاخيره فذلك
يؤدي الى صعوبه انتاج بعضها قسم المهام
الكبيره الى خطوات قصيره رابعا عدم تفضيل
مصالح الاخرين هناك خيط رفيع يفصل بين ان
يكون الشخص لطيفا او سهلا المنال فمحاوله
التواجد مع الجميع سيستنزف وقتك وقدرتك
على تلبيه احتياجاتك الشخصيه خامسا اهمال
الرعايه الذاتيه فالحماس والرغبه في سرعه
الانجاز ينبغي ان لا تتم على حساب صحتك
الجسديه والعقليه اخيرا الرضا وعدم
المقارنه بالاخر لان كل شخص مسار مختلف
فان لم تصادف النجاح فخذ الموقف كعبره
ودرس وخبره عمليه على كل حال سالنا الناس
في العراق ما هي العاده اليوميه التي تؤمن
بانها سبب نجاحك نتابع الاجابات
[موسيقى]
يومي راح يكون حلو احكي ويا والدتي
بالتليفون اخابره اعز صديقه عندي مثلا
اعزم صديقاتي اقول لهم اني عازمتكم اليوم
على ترويقه يعني هي صباحيه او فتشي
العمليه مبنيه عنا نجاح وانت تخلق النجاح
من ايدك يعني يعني يوم سلبي اذا تريد تسوي
يوم سلبي انت انت اي شغله تفكر بيها اكثر
من مره راح يطلع يومك كله
[موسيقى]
اقعد اتصوح بنشاط بحيويه مبتسم اروح
للدوام وباهس دائما اقعد الصبح ابحث عن
الناس الفقره على مود اساعدهم على مود
يصير يومي جميل احلى صباح مع الشعب
العراقي ويسمع القران واحد ويسمع فيروز
اهدينا في الاستوديو المدربه المعتمده في
تطوير اداه شهد العبدولي اهلا بك يا هلا
صباح الخير يا مرحبا صباح النور والسرور
هلا فيكم طيب دراسه تتحدث عن الست عادات
وست نقاط اذا غيرناها تتغير حياتنا هل هذه
فقط هي الامور اللي ممكن اذا غيرناها نصبح
اكثر سيطره على حياتنا واكثر نجاحا ام انه
في امور اخرى يعني هل تتفقي بعرفش اذا
سمعتيهم كمان في البدايه نصبح عليكم
بالخير ثانيا اذا اردت ان تحصل على شخص
يساعدك في تغيير حياتك فانظر الى المراه
الشخص الى المراه الشخص هو مرات ذاته انت
شنو تبين تغيرين انت تقدرين تشوفين نفسك
وتعرفين شنو النواقص وتغيرينها ولكن سبحان
الله هناك بعض الامور اللي حتى ديننا
الحنيف ورسولنا صلى الله عليه وسلم وصى
الامه العربيه عليها لما قال انه يوصي
امته بالبكور دائما البكور في بدايه اليوم
وفي بدايه الصباح هذه كانت توصيه من
الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم فنعم هناك بعض
الامور العامه اللي لو تم تغييرها راح
يعني تغير وتاثر على حياه الانسان ولكن في
الاصل الشخص يغير ما يعيق تطوره طيب خليني
اسالك اليوم انه انا استيقظت باكرا لكن
حياتي لا تبدا باكرا فبالتالي ما اهميه
انه انا استيقظ باكرا بينما مثلا عملي
يبدا الساعه 11 او ربما في وقت متاخر هل
هذه الدراسه تضع هي هذه الاولويات او
النقاط الست اذا اتبعناها من الممكن ان
تتغير حياتنا ونصبح افضل اولا رب العالمين
وضع لنا منهج حياه فلما نحن نقوم في
الخامسه صباحا او لما الخبراء يقولون
نوم خفق قيلوله ما في مشكله الامور طيبه
ولكن بكور ليش البكور لانه اول شيء الله
سبحانه وتعالى اعطانا او وضع لنا منهج
رباني اللي هي الصلوات الخمس هذه الصلوات
الخمس هي اللي خلنا نقول اللي تدوه حق
اليوم عشان ترتب لنا
وترجع تنام لكن انا اقصد الشروع في عمل
اليوم ليش انا ابدا باكرا اذا اذا عملي
متاخر ليش اني انا ما البي احتياجات
الاخرين واقوم بهذه المهام ولازم اكون
اناني واهتم
بتفاصيلي
من الشعر الشعر بتتحدث عن انه النوم لكم
من دقيقه زياده عن الوقت المبكر اللي انت
عاده تصحى فيه او يعني نص ساعه او ساعه
هذا اشي مفيد وبالعكس يعني ممكن يكون سر
نجاحك بعكس اليوم الصبح الصبح يعني الصبح
بعكس ما بنتوقع بانه يعني يكون في عندك
روتين معين هذا شيء مفيد
بعدك على النجاح بس في هناك كاتبين انا
اعتبرهم بعد ايضا من عرابه هذه الامور
اللي هو روبن شارما صاحب كتاب نادي
الخامسه صباحا وايضا ميل روبنز اللي يقول
قاعده الخمس ثواني هذين الكتابين شو
يتكلمون عن شو بالضبط الكتاب الاول نادي
الخامسه صباحا يقول انه لازم الشخص يكون
عنده روتين يقوم من الصبح وبعدين يتبع
قانون 2020 مثل ما تفضلت حضرتك وقلت يمكن
انه ما عنده شيء يسويه ولكن عشرين عشرين
عشرين وبعدين ينام ما عندي فيها مشكله على
الاقل انجز فيها شيء شو تقول هذه القاعده
انه لما يقوم الساعه خمسه الصبح وبعدين
يتبع عشرين الاولى اللي هي التمرين اكثر
سايزنج اول شيء انت لازم تسوي انك تحرك
الدوره الدمويه اللي عندك في جسمك وفي
دكتور ايضا طلع يقول لك ان انت لما تقوم
من الخمسه للثمانيه لما تكون قاعد من
الخمسه للثمانيه انت تحمي نفسك من العرضه
من انه يتعرض الى الجلطات القلبيه وهذه
طبيا اثبتت طبيا
فعندك عشرين الاولى اللي هي اكثر سايزك
تمرين العشرين الثانيه تامل ان انت تقعد
تتامل في في نفسك تتامل في وضعك تتامل في
امورك تحطيلك سكاجي لينك تحطيلك تدولست
مهام وتعلم عشرين دقيقه تعلم انت معناته
اذا ضربتها ب 360 الرقم اللي يعطيك هذا
مجموع محصل ما تتعلمه يوميا بعد ما تخلص
حط راسك ابوي وارقد شويه واخذ لك
يعني ممكن انا اقصد انا اقصد ان الناس
اللي تحطي لها روتين معين
نعم على حسب كل شخص في في ناس بكونوا
بيحبو وبالمناسبه ليليين وفي ناس نظريين
وهذا يعتمد على متن ولد هذا الشخص يعني
مثلا اللي قدامكم انسانه ليليه انا مولوده
الساعه سبعه مساء في عشرين احد عشر مولوده
عشان يعرف عيد ميلادي مولوده السابعه مساء
فانا وايد انسانه ليليه نعم اقدر انتج
الصبح بس انتاجي الغزير يكون في الليل
وهذا ايضا ينعكس على انماط شكرا جزيلا لك
المدربه المعتمده في تطوير الذات شهد
العبدولي شكرا شكرا لمتابعتي المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات